Olá minhas amigas meus amigos para mais
um vídeo é um prazer estar aqui com
vocês Dr Alan Dutra vamos falar hoje
como resolver a língua branca com 10
soluções caseiras bem pessoal sabemos
que a língua é crucial para várias
funções corporais é muito importante pra
gente poder falar saborear engolir e é
esse órgão língua considerado um
indicador de saúde na medicina
tradicional chinesa então uma língua
branca pode sinalizar vários problemas
de saúde entre exemplos candidíase oral
mais higiene oral servindo Então como um
alerta para possíveis outras condições
de saúde Então o que podemos interpretar
ao ver uma língua branca trata--se de
uma condição caracterizada pela presença
de um revestimento branco na superfície
da língua resultante do acúmulo de
restos de comida bactérias células
mortas Embora geralmente seja inofensiva
e temporária ela pode se indicar
infecções ou condições de saúde mais
sérias Então vamos discutir um pouco
mais sobre as causas da língua branca
uma das causas mais comum é desidratação
e boca seca Então são ambientes
propícios para o crescimento bacteriano
devido à falta de saliva o que pode ser
apenas por falta de beber água ou uso de
algum Medic ento ou alguma condição de
saúde como doença autoimune ou ainda
problema nas glândulas salivares outra
causa de língua branca é a ma higiene
bucal a falta de limpeza adequada que
permite o acúmulo de substâncias na
língua então doenças ou infecções e
febre também podem ser causas podem
alterar a cor da língua como sinal de
inflamação geral no corpo também reações
alguns medicamentos pode provocar língua
branca por exemplo os antibióticos eles
podem promover o crescimento de
leveduras de fungos né e alterar a flora
bucal também o uso de fumo tabaco e
Álcool o uso pode contribuir para a
descoloração da língua e afetar a saúde
bucal dando aquele aspecto saboroso à
língua algumas condições de saúde
específicas como doenças cardíacas
congênitas o HIV barra aides a
leucoplasia e a língua geográfica cada
um delas afetando a língua de maneiras
distintas então em casos de infecções
por fungos especialmente Cândida que é
uma causa bem comum de língua branca
então isso causa candidiase oral onde o
crescimento excessivo do Fungo Cândida
leva um revestimento branco na
superfície da língua Cândida é uma forma
de levedura ou fungo que naturalmente
habita o nosso corpo então em quantidade
descontroladas ela faz parte da flora
não costuma causar problemas de saúde
mas quando está em excesso vai causar
sim a língua branca na presença de
condições favoráveis como a diminuição
das bactérias amigas as bactérias do
sistema normal de defesa do organismo
então na diminuição das bactérias boas
isso vai gerar uma disbiose e uma causa
disso é uma dieta rica em açúcares então
a cândida vai se prifer nessas condições
e ela pode mudar para uma forma de
doença uma forma patogênica e vai sair
do controle essa versão mais agressiva
da cândida é capaz de aderir mais
efetivamente à superfície do corpo e
penetrar nas Barreiras celulares
causando infecções e sintomas Associados
à candidíase Então quais são os sintomas
de crescimento excessivo de Cândida
desejo por açúcar excessivo por cab
hidratos coceira nas partes íntimas nas
mucosas língua branca fadiga infecção do
trato urinário ou genital de repetição
ou recorrente inchaço no abdômen
distensão abdominal problemas digestivos
congestão nasal ou sinusite problemas de
pele articulações doloridas e hálito de
amônia Então como nós fazemos para
resolver quais sãoos tratamentos que
você consegue facilmente DEC
fazer para língua branca então um
primeiro tratamento muito utilizado é o
bicarbonato de sódio que ele age como
agente exfoliante removendo células
mortas restos de comida e bactérias Além
disso ajuda a neutralizar a acidez da
boca criando um ambiente menos propício
ao crescimento de bactérias e outros
organismos nocivos Mas pode não ser tão
eficaz se a causa for fungos segundo
ponto que você pode utilizar em casa
alimentos fermentados porque eles são
prebióticos eles têm fibras que servem
de comidinha PR as bactérias boas e
também tem as próprias bactérias boas
são probióticos também então eles são
simbióticos tem prebiótico e probiótico
eles podem restabelecer o equilíbrio da
fla intestinal ajudando na prevenção e
tratamento da candidiase da boca na
redução da língua branca terceiro ponto
você pode fazer bochecho com óleo de
coco que é uma técnica da medicina e
orveda indiana que ajuda a remover
bactérias em excesso também as toxinas
da boca promovendo o ambiente da boca ou
bucal saudável então o óleo de coco é
recomendado Devido as suas propriedades
antibacterianas e antifúngicas eu tenho
um vídeo específico sobre isso veja o
meu vídeo sobre como fazer o bochecho o
link vai estar na descrição e tem quatro
é o sal marinho integral possui
propriedades antibacterianas e
antifungicas que ajudam ajuda a combater
a formação da camada branca na língua
então gargarejos com água com sal
integral podem limpar a área atuar como
esfoliante natural o quito item é o
extrato de semente de toranja o extrato
de semente de toranja ele é reconhecido
por suas propriedades antimicrobianas
que são bem Poderosas incluindo ação
antifúngica que torna ele um remédio
natural eficaz no combate a infecções
como é o caso da candidíase o sexto item
que nós vamos discutir aqui é o suco de
babosa ou Aloe Vera ele é conhecido por
suas propriedades curativas
antibacterianas e antifungicas então
suco de Aloe Vera ou babosa pode ser
usado para enxaguar a boca isso vai
ajudar a eliminar a camada branca e
promover a cura de irritações bocais o
sétimo item um ponto um pouquinho mais
polêmico porque eu já tive vídeo sobre
isso aqui no canal e que o YouTube não
gostou removeu esses vídeos mas vamos
falar rapidamente da prata coloidal é um
antimicrobiano que pode ser utilizado
para combater infecções na boca ele é
considerado natural incluindo ele pode
combater as causas de língua branca
então usar prata coloidal diluída como
enxaguante bucal pode ajudar a eliminar
bactérias e fungos o oitavo item é o
alho O alho é rico num alimento muito
interessante a alicina que é um
antibiótico natural um antifúngico
natural el tem fortes propriedades
antifungicas e o áo pode combater a
candidíase oral que é uma das causas
mais comuns aí da língua branca então
consumir o áo cru ou em suplementos de
alho pode ajudar a reduzir a presença de
fungos na boca o nono item é o óleo de
orégano também é muito interessante
muito conhecido por suas propriedades
antifúngicas antibacterianas e
antiinflamatórias então o óleo de
orégano pode ser eficaz no tratamento da
candidíase oral e se for sistêmica essa
candidíase você pode tratar o quadro
completo então você pode usar
suplementos ou mesmo usar o chá em casa
do orégano usando como enxaguante bucal
o décimo item é o chá de paldarco esse
chá possui propriedades antifungicas
antiinflamatória sendo útil no
tratamento do crescimento excessivo de
Cândida na boca que pode levar a
aparecimento de língua branca você pode
consumir o chá regularmente ou usar para
fazer gargarejos então é importante
pessoal manter uma rotina de higiene
oral incluindo a escovação adequada dos
dentes e da gengiva da Raspagem da
língua é fundamental prevenir e tratar a
língua branca com essas medidas simples
também então a Raspagem regulada da
língua pode remover excesso de detritos
células mortas bactérias contribuindo
para uma boca muito mais saudável
prevenindo também o mau aleto associado
à língua branca então é importante
important lembrar que embora esses
tratamentos possam ser eficazes para
tratamentos de casos leves moderados de
língua branca condições persistentes ou
severas devem ser avaliados por um
profissional que tenha condições de ver
você um profissional de saúde para
garantir um diagnóstico e tratamento
adequado pode ser um dentista ou mesmo
médico que entenda desse assunto pessoal
foi um grande prazer tlo aqui com vocês
vocês são fera um beijo no coração de
vocês m